[Música]
el terremoto la derrotó murdagui o por
lo menos lo que queda de ella va a
quedar arrasada
[Música]
una ciudad de 40.000 habitantes el
equivalente a un pequeño Distrito en
cualquier mega urbe latinoamericana
borrada del mapa
en medio de este cementerio a cielo
abierto este epitafio en letras rojas
[Música]
adiós murdagui a 6 de febrero de 2023
nos vamos me rompe el corazón vivo aquí
desde mi infancia Aquí estaba mi
apartamento Pero eso se acabó es tan
triste
esta mujer llora su ciudad y lo que
perdió en ella su madre y sus dos
hermanos suspendida en una cuerda una
simple mesa transportada por su hijo que
recupera uno por uno los muebles que no
han sido destruidos
recuperamos las cosas pero ni siquiera
sabemos dónde vamos a meterlas no
tenemos ayuda estamos intentando
encontrar un apartamento en otra ciudad
pero los arriendos son muy elevados
Desde hace dos días nurdhi es un sálvese
quien pueda
nos han dicho que saquemos todas
nuestras pertenencias antes de que las
máquinas destruyan todo para recuperar
sus cosas sea cual sea el riesgo en casi
cada esquina hay grúas que se apoyan
sobre edificios abiertos en canal
inestables
este emprendedor pasa de una mudanza a
otra maniobra con mucha precaución
minucioso consciente del peligro si se
siente que las columnas del edificio no
son estables renunciamos es demasiado
peligroso para nosotros las autoridades
quieren hacer ahora de murdagui un
símbolo destruida de un soplo
reconstruida en un año en el mismo lugar
es su promesa
aseguran que no van a cometer los mismos
errores
a unos kilómetros de esta ciudad Este
agricultor nos muestra la única razón
que le mantiene allí a pesar del trauma
sus animales y sus campos
En dónde está el verde sembramos cebada
no podemos abandonar nuestra fuente de
recursos no sabemos hacer otra cosa soy
el único de los hermanos que estudió
Esto me necesitan aquí imposible dejar
lo que les hace sobrevivir Aunque eso
signifique vivir cerca de su casa
derrumbada en esta carpa con su familia
con las escasas pertenencias que pudo
rescatar como miles refugiados una sola
Esperanza que su ciudad vuelva algún día
a